lorsque notre agriculture souffre c'est
le pays tout entier qui souffrent la
vague de gel qui a frappé la france ces
derniers jours a eu des conséquences
calamiteuses
les pertes pour nos viticulteurs nos
arboriculteurs nos maraîchers et nos
grandes cultures sont désastreuses je
veux dire ici à nos agriculteurs notre
soutien sans faille une telle calamité
nous place face à une urgence vitale en
occitanie 70 500 % des cultures ont été
détruites par le gel pour la seule
viticulture lotoise c'est une perte de
revenus de plus de 50% qui s'annonce
pour 2022 90% des arbres fruitiers ne
donnerons pas de production pour cette
année pour notre agriculture notre
économie et pour les consommateurs le
coût sera terrible monsieur le ministre
le constat est sans appel et l'urgence
absolue
les déclarations traditionnels et les
mesures d'ordre technique ne suffiront
plus tous nos producteurs auront besoin
d'être massive celles et ceux nombreux
qui ne sont pas assurés tout comme ceux
qui le sont et pour qui le revenu le
niveau d'assurance ne couvrira pas les
pertes réelles l'année blanche fiscale
s'impose le décalage des pg e et une
annulation totale des charges sont
impératifs mais pour préparer l'avenir
il faut aller plus loin notre nation
doit s'organiser durablement pour faire
face à ces aléas climatiques de plus en
plus fréquent est de plus en plus
violents il nous faut une stratégie de
long terme la réforme du régime des
calamités mais aussi la création d'un
fonds national auquel chaque producteur
adhéreraient mutualisant budget
régionaux nationaux moyen des assureurs
et des banques
voilà un projet ambitieux sur lequel
nous devons avancer
monsieur le ministre je vous en fais la
proposition expérimentons un tel fonds
préventif pourquoi pas en régions
occitanes notre agriculture fait face à
un défi climatique nouveau la
responsabilité politique et d'être au
rendez vous